السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته.
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد
ان اله
الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
[Silence]
الله حي على
صلاه حي على
[Silence]
صلاه حي على الفلاح
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستع ونستعينه
ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد
ومن ومن يضلل فلن تجد له وليا مرشدا واشهد
ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد
ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك
على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين اما بعد معاشر الموحدين عباد
الله فان اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وان شر الامور محدثات
ها وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل بدعه ضلاله
وان كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله العظيم
رب العرش العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه ان
يجيرني واياكم منها انه ولي ذلك والقادر
عليه اما بعد فيقول الله سبحانه وتعالى يا
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الناس اتقوا
ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها
زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول
الله سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما اما
بعد لما قال الله سبحانه وتعالى والسابقون
السابقون اولئك المقربون قال النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بعدها لاصحابه وبشرى لنا
في كل قرن من امتي سابقون
قال في كل قرن من امتي سابقون اي في كل
قرن يعيد الله سبحانه وتعالى اليقين الى
نفوس الامه بان يجعل فيها سباقين في الخير
لا يبالون بالمحن ولا تاخذهم في الحق لومه
لائم وبهم يتاسى الناس والسابقون في عموم
الايه وليس الخصوص هم الذين يقول الله
سبحانه وتعالى
فيهم والذين يؤتون ما اتوا وقلوبهم وجله
انهم الى ربهم راجعون اولئك يسارعون في
الخيرات وهم لها سابقون في غير موضع في
القران جاء الارشاد الالهي فاستبقوا
الخيرات وسابقوا وسارعوا ولكل وجهه هو
موليها فاستبقوا الخيرات
اينما تكونوا ياتي بكم الله جميعا ان الله
على كل شيء قدير وسارعوا الى مغفره من
ربكم وجنه وجنه عرضها السماوات والارض
اعدت
للمتقين الذين ينفقون في السراء والضراء
والكاظمين الغيظ والعافين عن الناس والله
يحب المحسنين
الله سبحانه
وتعالى ايه سوره واقعه الله سبحانه
وتعالى والسابقون
السابقون اولئك
المقربون عربي
الله سبحانه
وتالىقون السابقون
والسابقون
السابقون الله سبحانه
وتعالى صلى الله عليه وسلم والسابقون
السابقون سابقون
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
because will
الله والسابقون السابقون
ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قران
وسابق compaders
[Silence]
لما تتامل الايات تجد في كل مجال من
مجالات الدنيا والدين جعل الله سبحانه
وتعالى بابا لنا بان نكون من السابقين
ادخل ايها ايها
شئت السابقون في حب الله وابتغاء مرضاته
والتماس ما يحب وترك ما يكره السابقون الى
المساجد والصلاه على وقتها السابقون الى
الى العبادات السابقون في الصدقات
السابقون الى اصلاح ذات البين السابقون في
نصره الضعيف السابقون في اجتناب ما حرم
الله السابقون في غض البصر وحفظ اللسان
السابقون في تعلم القران وتعليمه السابقون
في الاحسان الى الوالدين والضعفاء
واليتامى والمساكين السابقون في نشر الحق
والدعوه السابقون في ذب الاذى عن المظلوم
السابقون في بناء
المجتمعات ونشر الوعي والدين والسابقون في
التسبيح والتهليل والتكبير وذكر الله
والسابقون السابقون اولئك هم اولئك
المقربون الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
اللهقونبقونقون الله سبحانه
وتالى
رحمه والسابقون السابقون
المقربون
صلاه عباده
[Silence]
‏people الله made
forb anduners
رend
[Silence]
مساجد
الله تكبير تهليل تحميد لله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
والسابقون السابقون اولئك
المقربون
اعجل الى الله والى رضوانه كما عجل موسى
في الايه لما قال الله سبحانه وتعالى وما
اعجلك عن قومك يا موسى لما قالهم اولئ على
اثري ثم قال وعجلت اليك ربي
لترضى سو
هيسن الله سبحانه وتعالى
مو الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
موسى مو
اذان
اقامه
موعد رمضان
[Silence]
وعجلت اليك ربي
لترضى
الله
تفاسير موسى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله وسابق الى الله والى الخيرات كما
سابق زكريا وزوجه انهم كانوا يسارعون في
الخيرات ويدعوننا رغبا ورهبا وكانوا لنا
خاشعين الله
زكريا الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه
وتعالى اعجل الى
الله والصدقه كما عجل اليها النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم روى البخاري في صحيحه
عن عقبه قال صليت وراء النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم بالمدينه العصى فسلم ثم قام
مسرعا فتخطى رقاب الناس الى بعض حجر نسائه
ففزع الناس من
سرعته فخرج عليهم فراى انهم عجبوا من
سرعته فقال ذكرت شيئا من تبر عندنا قال
ذكرت شيئا من تبر عندنا فكرهت ان يحبسني
فامرت
بقسمته هم بالصدقه ولم يؤجلها صلى الله
عليه وسلم هم بالصدقه قام مسرعا من صلاته
انهم كانوا يسارعون في
الخيرات
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم في
قران صلى الله عليه
ط
عباده
حديث صلى الله عليه وسلم
عقبه عصر الله عليه
صلاه un how would norally do it so
people
am
prop said why are you amed said i was
thinking want for about that made him up
to quick act went
[Silence]
خير الله سبحانه وتالى
ان شاء
الله خطبه بارك الله لي ولكم بالقران
العظيم ونفعني واياكم بهدي سيد المرسلين
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم
على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم اجمعين ولعل السائل
ولعل السائل يسال لما الاستباق والمسارعه
في
الخيرات انت لا تسابق الناس بقدر ما تسابق
ما بقي لك من الايام انت لا تسابق الناس
بقدر ما تسابق ما بقي لك من صحه وشباب انت
لا تسابق الناس وانما تسابق غناك قبل فقرك
لما قال الله سبحانه وتعالى فاستبقوا
الخيرات فان
انسان فان الانسان لا يدري ماذا يعرض له
ولذلك قال صلى الله عليه وسلم عن ابي
هريره رضي الله عنه ان رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال بادروا بالاعمال سبعا قال
بادروا بالاعمال
سبعا اي اي افعل الخير قبل سبع اشياء
ذكرها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
بادروا بالاعمال سبعا هل تنظرون الا فقرا
منسيا او غنى مطيا او مرضا مفسدا او هرما
مفندا او موتا مجهزا او الدجال فشر غائب
ينتظر او الساعه فالساعه ادهى وامر ومن
فوائد التعجيل بالاعمال الصالحه في زمن
الرخاء والراحه والصحه والفراغ
والغنى انه من فعل ذلك عرفه الله سبحانه
وتعالى تعالى في اوقات الفتن والشدائد
فثبته وسلمه في دينه وكتب له اجر ما كان
يعمل وهو صحيح مقيم كما قال النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم تعرف اليه في الرخاء يعرفك
في الشده
[Silence]
‏question is you contr your life you do
not contr your health you do not contr
your
life you contr nothing of
that so delaying one day you not could
survive you cann that day that's way the
the speed in acting
[Silence]
‏people
comp between you time
الله سبحانه وتالى
about next
time
you صلى الله عليه بيرفوا
الحديث سبحانه وتعالى
الله خير
اللهعاء تعرف اليه في الشده يعرفك في
الرخاء
‏benit صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم خطبه
خير
الله فاستبقوا الى الخيرات اينما تكونوا
ياتي بكم الله جميعا ان الله على كل شيء
قدير اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
الاولين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
الاخرين وصل وسلم على محمد سيدنا محمد في
كل وقت وحين
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث
الارض ومن عليها وانت خير الوارثين اللهم
ارحم ضعفنا اللهم ارحم ضعفنا واجمع شملنا
واجبر كسرنا ويسر امرنا وفرج همنا واشرح
صدورنا ووسع ارزاقنا واقضي عنا ديننا
اللهم تقبل توبتنا واغسل حوبتنا واجب
دعوتنا وثبت حجه حجتنا واهد
قلوبنا وسدد السنتنا واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا
بفضلك يا رب العالمين اللهم اشف مرضانا
ومرضى المسلمين وارحم موتانا وموتى
المسلمين وعاف مبتلانا ومبتلى المسلمين
واجعل لنا بكل دعوه اجابه وبلغنا رضاك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي رايتي الحق والدين الدين المبين
اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل
مكان اللهم الطف باهل غزه الكرام اللهم
الطف باهل غزه الكرام وفي فلسطين المحتله
اللهم ارفع الكرب عنهم اللهم امن خوفهم
اللهم كن لهم معينا ومؤيدا ونصيرا اللهم
اجبر كسرهم وارحم شهيدهم وشافي جريحهم
واجعل لهم مخرجا وفرجا عاجلا عاجلا غير
اجل اللهم برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
يا لطيف يا لطيف الطف بهم اللهم اشدد
وطاتك على ابناء الشتات اللهم اشدد وطاتك
على ابناء الشتات فانهم لا يعجزونك اللهم
اشدد وطاتك وغضبك وعذابك على ابناء الشتات
اللهم احصهم عددا واقتلهم بددا ولا تغادر
منهم احدا اللهم اشف صدورنا وصدور قوم
مسلمين اللهم اجعل هذا المجتمع اللهم اجعل
هذا المجتمع امنا سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد
المسلمين اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات وتحمل
عنا التبعات اللهم اجزي سيدنا محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم عنا خير ما جزيت نبيا عن
امته اللهم احينا على سنته وامتنا على
ملته اللهم واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته
يا رب العالمين اللهم اللهم انا نوصيك
بوالدينا خيرا اللهم تجاوز عنهم السيئات
وتحمل عنهم التبعات بارك لهم في اعمارهم
واعمالهم واختم لنا ولهم بخاتمه الاحسان
يا حي يا قيوم برحمتك نستغيث اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد واله وصحبه
والتابعين واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا الخلل كلوز ذا جابس
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين اذا وقعت
الواقعه ليس لوقعتها
كاذبه خافضه
رافعه اذا رجت الارض
رجا وبست الجبال بسا
فكانت
هباء
منبثا
وكنتم
ازواجا
ثلاثه فاصحاب الميمنه
ما اصحاب
الميمنه واصحاب المشامه
مشامه
والسابقون
السابقون
اولئك
المقربون في
جنات
النعيم
ثله من
الاولين
ثله من الاولين
وقليل من
الاخرين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والسابقون
السابقون
اولئك
المقربون في
جنات
النعيم ثله من الاولين وقليل من
الاخرين على
سرر
موضونه متكئين عليها
متقابلين يطوف عليهم
ولدان
مخلدون
باكواب وباريق وكاس من
معين لا يصدعون عنها ولا
ينزفون
وفاكهه
مما
يشتهون
وفاكهه مما يتخيرون
ولحم طير
مما
يشتهون وحور عين كامثال اللؤلؤ
المكنون
جزاء بما كانوا
يعملون لا يسمعون فيها
لغوا ولا
تاثيما الا قيل لا
سلاما سلاما
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم رحمه الله وبركاته allர need
to just hear this quickly first and ‏for
there might not be a sign posted in
the street next door to us adjacent to
us but there's a speed limit and
unfortunately nobody follows a speed
limit it's not a race track it's not a
dr people are pulling out of both
service places residential places people
live on theet please slow down it's not
a it's not a competition who can get to
the first
secondly if you're pulling into the lot
there is more
‏sign that slow down there kids around
and speed
is on numerous occ I'm seeing
people in the in the on theet in the
paring lot doing at least 40 to 50 on
thatet and doing 30 an hour in the
parking
lot you know it just takes one time to
mess up or somebody to get h or somebody
get you know backed into and then your
day is ruined
‏minut another hour so all here comm
pleas slow down i don't call you
out again but i will call you out i
willing pi and sending you letter
personally sign so pleas that pleas and
be mindful there is kids around the who
are coming here for schooling so please
slow down pay atttion
‏schem sch
trans
sch
and
schn school after break so have in je
ins come back to summer school if you
need more inform come ask any of us in
the
انء الله
تعالى الله